hurricane Irma right now is taking aim
at North Florida the deadly storm has
lashed nearly every part of the state
Irma's Center passed overnight between
Tampa and Orlando it caused serious
flooding in some areas there are now
almost six million homes and businesses
across the state without electricity
irma is dumping huge amounts of rain
from one side of the state to the other
it is moving toward the Georgia border
where it's expected to become a tropical
storm and we are hearing some amazing
stories from people who were caught in
the storm and we have about a dozen of
our correspondents stationed around the
state of Florida we've managed to get
two hearted islands in the Florida Keys
and along the Gulf Coast but we begin
our coverage today with Jeff Glor he's
in st. Pete Beach that's near the mouth
of Tampa Bay Jeff good morning Gail I'd
like to tell you herma is over it is not
the surf has really picked up behind us
eight foot waves as this enormous storm
though weakened continues slicing its
way up the state of Florida overnight
Irma continued its slow crawl north
across Florida the storm this size in
the street has brought a significant
rise in water
bringing torrential rain and
hurricane-force winds
inland even as far north as Jacksonville
rain and howling wind arrived knocking
trees to the ground bad police helped
anyone they could in Sarasota they
rescued a trapped driver after a tree
fell in his car overnight in Orange
County the National Guard along with
local rescue crews helped evacuate 30
people from their homes after six feet
of water rushed into their neighborhood
the storm ripped the southwestern Gulf
Coast Marco Island Naples and Fort Myers
for the brunt 140 mile per hour wind
gusts powered sheets of rain flooding
streets and knocking out power to
millions
herma also appeared to spawn tornadoes
including this one near Fort Lauderdale
another tornado reportedly destroyed
homes in Palm Bay farther south Miami
was inundated with water
despite avoiding a direct hit from early
this morning much of the Florida Keys
remain cut off from the mainland police
have been unable to assess damage
irma knocked out power to much of this
island chain but relief is already
underway
we don't have a comprehensive insight
into what the damage is I don't have any
numbers on potential injuries we will
work on those things
tomorrow it at first light